let's talk about the air in China with
you guys probably have seen a lot about
you done a couple stories on it
residents beijing's yeah now which is
the pollution iraq
capital China's Hunan Province will last
Saturday they got a treat
they were provided with bright blue bags
up fresh hair yeah this sounds made up
for from a comedy movie
but not the case let's take a look clear
they got to go up
into a nearby mountain where the air
originated it's about 120 miles away
from the city that they live in
and that they got to suck down from air
for a while pretty good
and I what you can see on the right
there this is actual
hand air that is a can %uh air
that they're selling they're actually
selling that in China
and what did that remind me out well as
brother
plant baseball I can assure both you and
your viewers
that there's absolutely no air shortage
what they were
yet the cause I birthing room right now
yet thanks for calling and not reverse
the charges yep
by should
hadn't traveled yeah
bad Mel Brooks predicting the future in
space but I can't believe you made space
for rent even before
2011 right now with your partner
philippe i weld
you mentioned I think yeah I'm
part dole will do a little joke in there
this is actually pretty serious
is this crazy like is actually not that
there are parts of this planet right now
where they are living in so much
smog you know be some pictures where it
looks like pog
but it actually smug it is pure
pollution that they have to go to
Mountain
120 miles away a to get there
ya but if I want to give you the money
part first know the best when it says
the
the a Chinese a province received it
treat
on for every a a dream world yeah I
up it really is changed my perspective
on treats you know
I always like I love both gonna do to go
to Del Taco it'll be a tree
they're like we did get the rare that
you like an electric cigarette butt
yeah I did you know it air your own
frightening yes so frightening moment
like a
we've got a special thing for
self-defense airer
air was thinking about like have kids R
kids like you to read it as
people starving in africa is a given to
breathe yeah
people with no franchise yeah yeah
its it's frightening I'll in writing but
the can was kinda quit with the
catholics a pleasant and have a look
like a
like because I can seem like a bad way
to get a rather on Wearside okay you
made by
I think more pollution with overwhelming
I don't know if I can air so OK at this
point where they should do an
e-cigarette air air cigarette
when you get nicotine an air so it's
good and bad wouldn't like that where to
find the Asian Jenny McCarthy yes both
very few know we're talking about how
we're gonna have to take this story
before this
but cigarette the air it's all coming in
one yeah it was a big thing I am
is this what what can we do because you
know obviously this has something to do
with the amount of pollution that's
going up into
that I fire products from China is that
barrier so it should be over
do we owe the iPhones have an iPhone yes
for my
so we all riding with my roommate I
you that diana Boggia an even tighter
you know I like I like I want to keep
the chinese input
okay but not for up but what really when
we do that cuz they're going through
their industrial revolution now
much like India we've done it already so
do we have any right
to tell them what to do because look
mean that a revenge legally get over
here we know that the water
from Fukushima is coming to our yeah the
west coast in the united states are now
like we're all connected
I'm so what we do stop party no more
party party out part that out there that
are good
yet %uh part serb at with this so they
could tell us that you know they have
yeah part time with her chariot bottled
water
I well yeah it's just it's really
disturbing that that
Chinese go to is not to like our with
crack down on the pollution that
was really you know figure out how we're
going to air quality that's rated and
it's like bad ship these people on a bus
to like a higher area
gears a little tree then get back down
there looks like you know what it looks
like it looks like when
the emergency landing system on an
airplane yeah meet up again with no the
image of God sees everything
but with Russian airplane drop in
altitude
yeah that is yeah it does look like that
but it can you imagine I mean
you know it look at the Z we can joke
about it but I mean these poor people
had to actually leave their homes
and travel 120 miles into a mountain for
hair I mean this is happening on planet
Earth is this just like proof for every
science fiction movie ever
I mean every week we do a story that I
feel like science fiction is actually
coming true how young like we are
destroying our
yeah and the you know we're gonna have
to move to Mars pretty good
yeah I mean I'm NEVER I was never one
for investing in any type in space
travel honestly
I feel like I'm the only when they get
adamantly opposed to lick anything
method as except for their dead space 3
well
you know like hey I just don't think
it's fair if you know what I was most
come under all the crazy to me that we
spend like
one billion dollars on my part so I'm
old and
no one has text books like I it makes me
insane
but then you hear the stories you know I
go well we gotta get outta this night at
some point down
yeah do we have in the planet at some
point yes right yes we do
we do we do you get air can air and yes
it actually go and it just take yeah
up